[Music]
straight ahead on long crime daily
amber heard takes the stand in the
defamation case with ex-husband johnny
depp i didn't care in that moment
if
he did kill me which was
likely in confronting him at that stage
of our lives
i didn't even care anymore at this
moment i was
he had already ripped my heart out plus
it became clear to me he was like
looking for something proceeds to do a
cavity search heard recounts an alleged
sexual assault incident early on in a
relationship with depp and depp's
attorney have a powerful reaction when
heard mentions kate moss i just in my
head instantly think of kate moss and
the stairs
and i
swung at him but first heard says depp
sexually assaulted her with a liquor
bottle it wasn't him was black
i've never been
so scared of my life long crime daily
covering court cases from coast to coast
[Applause]
[Music]
welcome everyone to law and crime daily
i'm your host brian buckmeyer as week
four of the johnny depp versus amber
heard trial comes to a close not only
are we bringing you the top highlights
from this week in court but we're also
breaking down how each side testified to
those events
for the first time we're hearing from
defendant amber hurd who took the stand
on wednesday her testimony comes as part
of a multi-million dollar defamation
suit stemming from herd's 2018
washington post op-ed about domestic
violence while depp was never mentioned
in the article he argues readers know he
was publicly linked to heard depp filed
a 50 million dollar lawsuit against his
ex-wife claiming damages but heard shot
back with a hundred million dollar suit
doubling down on her domestic violence
claims on thursday she told jurors about
the night depp's fingertip was cut off
we want to warn you the next clip will
cover the topic of sexual assault with
an account of such by amber heard while
she took the stand we understand this
can be difficult to watch so viewer
discretion is advised
i felt this pressure i felt this
pressure
he on my pubic bone
he thought
i just saw his arm i could feel his arm
moving and i
it looked like he was
punching
me
but i could just feel this pressure
it was like
kind of hitting me
it didn't feel pain it was just a
pressure on my
pubic bone and
i remember
looking at all the broken bottles
broken glass
and i remember that it's just
not wanting to move
because i didn't know if it was broken i
didn't know if the bottle
that he had inside me was broken
heard testify she took sleeping pills
after the incident and woke up to find
depp's fingertip missing in the in the
australian house covered in paint and
blood while on the stand last month depp
told a different story about how his
fingertip was cut
she threw the large bottle
and it
made contact
and shattered
everywhere
and
i honestly didn't i didn't feel the pain
at first at all i felt no pain
whatsoever
what i felt was
um
i felt
heat i felt heat and i felt
as if something were dripping down my
hand you know
and then i
looked down and
realized that the
the
the tip of my finger
had been
severed
and
i was
looking directly at
my bones
joining us today is civil rights
attorney joe richardson and co-host
terry austin joe j depp has to prove by
a preponderance or more than 50 percent
that herd's claim of domestic abuse are
false how does he do that with these two
stories especially where heard says she
was asleep for most of it
you have to when you're dealing with
defamation you're talking about a false
statement of purported fact and so you
can't get around the notion that you
have to look at common sense and the
extent to which
other things testimony of other people
and things like that could potentially
shed some light on the jury as to
whether or not this actually happened or
in depth's case didn't happen as he says
that it didn't happen it's not an easy
thing because none of us were there but
i think you have to look at the
surrounding facts including what other
witnesses would have to say and see
whether or not it comports with our
traditional notions of common sense
right corroboration seems to be the name
of the game here terry it seems like
hurt is claiming either she doesn't
remember or she was sound asleep when
most of this mayhem occurred that
evening what are your thoughts about
that
you know domestic violence is a very
serious allegation but amber hurt is
simply just not credible march 8th was a
very unforgettable day a lot happened
that day death lost the tip of his
finger she's claiming that he sexually
assaulted her but for some reason she
doesn't remember anything but the sexual
assault she doesn't remember that she
threw bottles or she said she threw it
and it fell in front of her she says
that he threw all these bottles at her
so i think it's just not credible that
she took these sleeping pills and then
she woke up the next day and all of a
sudden she recognized that he lost his
fingertip and she thought he must have
done it while he was smashing the phone
not not credible we'll see how that
works out on cross examination still
ahead on law and crime daily our johnny
depp and amber heard coverage continues
amber heard admits to getting physical
with johnny depp but does her story
contradict previous witness testimony
[Music]
welcome back we're looking closer now at
testimony by amber hurd on thursday she
told jurors she got physical with depp
for the first time after he took a swing
at her sister
whitney my sister
all of a sudden put herself
in between johnny and i
she just threw herself
like in the line of fire or whatever she
just
all of a sudden there was trying to get
johnny to stop
her back was to the staircase
and
johnny swings at her
and i just
see my little sister with her back on
face
her back to the staircase
and johnny swings at her and i don't
even
wait don't even wait
for
any other i don't hesitate i don't wait
i just in my head instantly think of
kate moss and the stairs
and i
swung at him and all of my relationship
to date with johnny
i hadn't landed a blow
and i
for the first time hit him
hurts testimony comes just three days
after depth security guard and a witness
of the fight told a different story
about that same fight
i felt it was time to get mr depp out of
the situation so i stepped
in between miss hurd and mr depp um
telling
mr depp that we were that we were
leaving and that it wasn't up to him
anymore
um
at that point
out of the corner of my eye i saw a
fist
and an arm come
across my right shoulder and uh
i heard and saw a
closed
captioning not
mr
available
push or shove whitney hurd correct
absolutely not and it was only after mr
depp pushed whitney that amber stepped
forward and punched him in the face
isn't that right
that is not correct
eli fans took note that during herd's
testimony about the argument depp's
attorney can be seen giving a fist pump
at the mention of deb's ex-girlfriend
kate moss take a look
i just in my head instantly think of
kate moss and the stairs
and i
swung at him i just in my head instantly
think of
kate moss and the stairs
and i
swung at him
terry depp previously described himself
as a southern gentleman do you think the
jury believes he would punch a woman
you know what the evidence so far just
doesn't support that theory here's what
the evidence supports so far brian as
far as i'm concerned depp is a very
generous man he's very kind to all the
people around him whether they're
working for him or not it does show that
he drinks a lot he has a high tolerance
for alcohol he smokes cigarettes and
marijuana
but his disposition doesn't change and
when he yells he gets angry and he does
curse and he does hit cabinets but so
far the evidence just doesn't support
that he would hit a woman he hasn't done
it in the past we haven't seen that and
so no i don't think he uh would hit a
woman and i don't think the jury thinks
he would either yeah now joe i want to
see if you can make heads or tails of
this for us because heard alluded to an
abusive moment between depp and
ex-girlfriend kate moss but depp's team
got pretty excited about that what could
that mean
well it means that they think that she
has opened the door to kate moss
potentially testifying
and so once she brings something in the
issue now can come in at the very least
to impeach what it is that she's saying
and so therefore it allows him to do two
things first of all there's a public
information war here and a public pr war
it helps him with the public it reminds
them that potentially if she testifies
in his favor that he's a good guy and if
he's a good guy and she's the bad guy it
makes it more possible that in fact she
is defaming him and therefore it gets
him towards the way to winning the case
yeah i believe like this relationship
was back in the early to mid 90s and
there may be public statements that he
never abused or maybe those public
statements can be used to win feature of
course we'll see as that trial resumes
in the in the days coming coming up on
law and crime daily our coverage
continues of amber heard's testimony in
the destination case against johnny depp
the actress tells her side of the story
of an incident between the two exes on a
flight plus what deb's friend testified
to weeks ago
[Music]
welcome back to law and crime daily and
more now on the defamation trial of
johnny depp versus amber heard as her
takes to stand on thursday she told
jurors about an alleged incident on an
airplane one they already heard about
from another witness from other
witnesses
and he starts throwing things at me ice
cubes utensils
he's calling me a
a go-getter and then an embarrassment
talking about what an embarrassment i am
he sits down in front of me at one point
and he slaps my face
and
his
friend
is in our proximity
it was the first time that anything like
that had happened in front of somebody i
got up
to move again and he's just taunting me
having a laugh screaming
and then just straight up mean calling
me names as i get up
he kind of kicks the swivel chair into
my hip but kind of just hits me
and i look at him
and he asks me what what are you gonna
do about it i just stared at him it felt
like there was a blackness in his eyes
as i'm walking away he tells me to hurry
up and i just
look at him one more time
wanting to penetrate the monster to see
the man that i love underneath that
two weeks ago jurors heard from keenan
wyatt a friend of depp's who also works
as a hollywood sound engineer wyatt told
jurors his side of the story on that
flight from boston to los angeles
what if any conversation did you have
with
am miss heard on the flight well at one
point i went up to her and said uh
something to the effect of you know he
cares about you and all of a sudden she
snapped
and started yelling at me i went back to
a seat and minded my own business
when she said those things to you
would you describe the tone of her voice
if you remember it she she was abruptly
loud it was a quiet plane all of a
sudden it got very loud you get on the
airplane and it's your testimony
that
ms heard
had a a bad tone of voice with mr depp
is that correct uh she had a bad tone of
voice with me
wasn't mr depp saying pretty horrible
things to ms heard i don't recall that
heard said that depth kicked her in the
back and knocked her off her feet do you
think she needs to bring a witness or
something else to corroborate her story
absolutely and we were talking about
this earlier you're going to have to
have someone who supports what she has
to say we've seen that depp's security
team and others around him have
supported his version of these stories
she's saying that she fell down and that
he kicked her in the back and no one
helped her those are some serious
allegations maybe no one helped her
because it didn't happen maybe no one
helped her because she wasn't injured so
i think if she's going to prove that
allegation she's going to have to bring
someone who supports exactly what she
has to say we haven't seen that yet on
the other hand on the other hand though
joe hurt has already laid the groundwork
for attacking these witnesses in the
op-ed uh her story about depp holding
this dog out of the window and others
that depp's team either looks the other
way or covers up for him so do you think
that this witness mcgirvin was uh doing
that
there's an argument that he was but
again i think where you have to go is
and the totality of the witness is the
totality of the evidence that's
presented the surrounding uh situations
issues the things that give you context
is what uh amber heard saying ringing
true uh does it make sense does it does
it follow logic that absolutely no one
seems to corroborate it whereas mr dev's
situation is corroborated on some level
none of us were there and there's a
possibility of either way there's
certainly a highly dysfunctional
relationship but does that take him
necessarily to the point of being an
abuser not necessarily but she's going
to have like terry says to show some
other things for him to be less
believable in the totality all right
we'll see how it continues as more
testimony rolls in when we come back
more on amber heard direct examination
in the defamation trial with ex-husband
johnny depp up next depp versus her
testimony on an incident early in the
couple's relationship
welcome back continuing our coverage of
the johnny depp v amber her defamation
trial amber heard took the stand for the
first time wednesday recalling an
incident she says happened while the
couple visited the hicksville trailer
palace in 2013. again we do want to warn
you this clip covers the topic of sexual
assault which can be difficult to hear
so viewer discretion is advised
when the mdma hit her she kind of
you know we were sitting around and
can't fire all of us and she kind of
just leaned into me
and put her
you know head on my shoulder
and kind of grab my arm johnny um
gets really
activated he gets really upset it seemed
like he turned all that rage onto the
trailer itself he hit with his hand um a
wall sconce he comes into the bedroom
area it became clear to me he was like
looking for something i kind of like
gestured to him and i said
like
what am i where am i good at what am i
hiding and where am i gonna hide it he's
like grabbing my my my breasts he's
touching my thighs
and he rips my underwear off
he was telling me we're doing we're
gonna we're gonna conduct a cavity
search shall we
i
like
just shoved his fingers inside me
i just i just
just stood there staring at the stupid
light
when johnny depp was on the stand he
gave his own account of what led up to
the argument on their trip
and so you removed kelly sue's hand from
amber and you yelled at kelly sue and
told her that amber was your girl right
that's not correct that's not correct no
sure
after this
uh incident you went back into the
trailer that you and miss heard were
were sharing you had an argument with
miss heard and you understood her to be
upset with the way that you had handled
um that situation with kelly sue correct
i mean i recall that
that was a a part of the argument i was
protecting ms hurd's
honor and i was protecting my girl you
would agree with me mr depp that
at a minimum you smashed up a bathroom
sconce during that argument correct
yes sir i punched i punched a um a glass
a
bathroom sconce
so joe depp has to prove this cavity
search the sexual assault allegation is
false as part of the way to win this
case what facts do you think his lawyers
will use to argue that
well you know again our challenge is we
have to actually believe
actors right which of the actors do we
believe what's what's real and what's
fake and they're going to have to point
to her lack of credibility to say
implicitly or from that deducting from
that that in fact he is credible and
therefore the assaults that are being
alleged did not happen that's not
necessarily an easy thing he might be
winning the public war outside in pr but
whether he's winning the war with a jury
is a separate thing but again the other
witnesses really help and how much this
comports with common sense and this
connects with what's going on if they
don't believe her they are more likely
to believe him make sense terry heard
admitted that she took mdma in
hicksville could that affect the jury's
opinion about herd's recollection of the
events
absolutely no question about it you know
mdma is commonly called ecstasy and it
is a drug it's used primarily for
recreational purposes and amber
testified to that and what it does is
that it relaxes you it enhances and
alters your sensations and a jury could
absolutely believe that her recollection
of what occurred was based on her drug
use clearly domestic violence as i said
earlier is very very serious but i think
they could
believe that because she took a drug
that it is altering her perception of
what actually happened that day yeah
well thank you for that tara and of
course i know she took like mushrooms
and mdma so that all could affect that
there well thank you both and thank you
for joining us here on long crime daily
we'll see you next time as we discuss
justice in america
[Music]
so
[Music]
you